Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. The American Civil War was an extraordinary narrative of twists and turns, death-defying escapes and thrilling cliffhangers. But no cliffhanger was more exciting than that on which we ended the last episode with Professor Adam Smith of Oxford University poised to answer my question, cruelly cut off actually, very rudely cut off some might say, from answering my question about whether the surrender at Appomattox when Robert E. Lee threw in the towel to the Union General Ulysses Escort, whether in that moment were the seeds of some of the later problems that the United States had with reconstruction, with the legacy of the war, and particularly with the idea of the lost cause and the South having fought for this noble cause.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余味》。美国内战是一段充满曲折、死里逃生和惊心动魄悬念的非凡叙事。但没有任何悬念比我们上一集结尾处更令人激动了：牛津大学的亚当·斯密教授正准备回答我的问题——实际上是被残酷地打断了，有些人可能会说非常粗鲁地打断了——关于阿波马托克斯投降事件，即罗伯特·E·李向联邦将军尤利西斯·格兰特投降的那一刻，是否埋下了美国后来在重建时期、战争遗产，特别是“迷途事业”（Lost Cause）理念以及南方为这一崇高事业而战的观念上所面临问题的种子。
And they're all friends again and hurrah, hurrah, and all of that stuff. So, Adam, what's the story? Do you think Appomattox was a problem? You are entirely correct, in my view, Dominic. So that's why Dominic wanted it answered so urgently. I see now. When Robert E. Lee surrendered, he issued a message to his troops in which he said, after four years of arduous service marked by unsurpassed courage and fortitude,
他们又成了朋友，万岁，万岁，诸如此类。那么，亚当，故事是怎么回事？你认为阿波马托克斯是一个问题吗？在我看来，多米尼克，你完全正确。所以这就是为什么多米尼克如此急切地想要得到答案。我现在明白了。当罗伯特·E·李投降时，他向部队发布了一则消息，其中说道，经过四年以无与伦比的勇气和坚韧为标志的艰苦服役，
the Army of Northern Virginia has been compelled to yield to overwhelming numbers and resources. In that sentence, you have the lost cause myth encapsulated. That is the essence of it. Lee, as you said at the end of the last episode, and his officers were allowed to keep their sidearms. They were allowed to keep their horses if they had them, and they were allowed to ride back into private life. Lee went on to become a college president, and there was no hint or serious threat of prosecution or any kind of treatment that you might expect a traitor to a country to suffer having led a failed rebellion
北弗吉尼亚军团被迫向压倒性的数量和资源屈服。在那句话里，你概括了“迷途事业”的神话。这就是它的精髓。正如你在上一集结尾所说，李和他的军官们被允许保留他们的随身武器。如果他们有马，他们被允许保留马匹，并被允许骑马回到私人生活中。李后来成为了一所大学的校长，没有任何暗示或严重的起诉威胁，也没有任何你可能预料到的叛国者在领导了一场失败的叛乱后会遭受的待遇。
he he didn't get his u.s citizenship back though did he because i i know this because i um i read yesterday that actually the person who did grant him his citizenship back was um dominic's old friend president gerald ford apparently very great man Very great man. But not infallible. But I hadn't realized that. So do they remain kind of non-citizens? So the leaders of the Confederacy were prescribed and had to petition. Only the leaders. Only the leaders. And they had to petition for to be allowed to vote,
但他没有恢复美国公民身份，对吧？因为我昨天读到，实际上批准他恢复公民身份的人是多米尼克的老朋友杰拉尔德·福特总统，显然是个非常伟大的人。非常伟大的人。但并非不会犯错。但我之前没意识到这一点。所以他们仍然算是非公民吗？邦联的领导人被剥夺了权利，必须请愿。只有领导人。只有领导人。他们必须请愿才能被允许投票，
essentially to be allowed back into full citizenship. And many of them, most of them probably were in the years after the war. But Lee was a bit too prominent. And in any case, he died before. I mean, he died in 1870. So, you know, he might have had some success a few years later. To tie up one of the loose end, Jefferson Davis,
本质上是为了被允许恢复完全的公民身份。他们中的许多人，可能大多数人，在战后几年里都这样做了。但李太显眼了。无论如何，他在那之前就去世了。我是说，他死于1870年。所以，你知道，几年后他可能会取得一些成功。为了解决一个悬而未决的问题，杰斐逊·戴维斯，
the president of the Confederacy, we'll come to the president of the Union and what happens to him in a second, but the president of the Confederacy, what happens to Jefferson Davis? Well, he is in prison for a couple of years. It's quite a luxurious imprisonment and he uses his time to write a book in which he makes the case that this great rebellion that he's led was all about constitutional principle and nothing at all to do with slavery. So already they're starting to rewrite the history. White Southerners are rewriting history from even before Appomattox actually, but certainly from after Appomattox, that the war was not about slavery. But Adam, here's an interesting thing though. So in 1861, when they broke away, a moment we haven't talked about,
邦联的总统，我们稍后再谈联邦的总统以及他的遭遇，但邦联的总统，杰斐逊·戴维斯发生了什么？嗯，他被监禁了几年。那是一段相当奢华的监禁，他利用这段时间写了一本书，在书中他辩称他所领导的这场伟大叛乱完全是关于宪法原则，与奴隶制毫无关系。所以他们已经在开始改写历史了。白人南方人实际上在阿波马托克斯之前，当然在阿波马托克斯之后，就已经在改写历史，声称战争与奴隶制无关。但亚当，这里有一件有趣的事情。在1861年，当他们分裂时，我们还没谈到那一刻，
the vice president of the Confederacy, Alexander Stevens, gives this incredibly famous speech. It's an inflammatory speech, really. I think it's called a cornerstone speech, isn't it? Where he basically says, let's make no bones about it. Our state is founded on white supremacy, on the idea that white people are better than black people. They always will be.
邦联的副总统亚历山大·斯蒂芬斯发表了这篇极其著名的演讲。这确实是一篇煽动性的演讲。我想它被称为“基石演说”，对吧？他在演讲中基本上说，让我们明确一点。我们的国家建立在白人至上主义之上，建立在白人优于黑人的观念之上。他们永远都会是这样。
There's an end to it. So white supremacy and slavery are right there in the Confederacy from the very beginning. So why is it, I mean, if they really believe in this, why is Jefferson Davis and why are other Southerners at the end of the war saying, oh, well, actually, no, it was just about states' rights and the Constitution?
这就是终点。所以白人至上主义和奴隶制从一开始就存在于邦联之中。那么，如果他们真的相信这一点，为什么杰斐逊·戴维斯和其他南方人在战争结束时会说，哦，好吧，实际上，不，这只是关于州权和宪法？
I mean, does that suggest that they had always secretly felt guilty about slavery? Or why have they ditched the principle for which they had fought so quickly at the end of the war? I know slavery has been abolished, but why aren't they still saying it was a disgrace that you abolished slavery? Slavery was brilliant. I mean, why are they not making that case? some of them some of them do make the case not that it was a disgrace that you abolished slavery so much as wasn't it a sad thing really you know much in the way that in chekhov plays there's a kind of nostalgia for the days of serfdom this notion that you know actually things were a lot more stable and
我的意思是，这是否暗示他们一直暗中对奴隶制感到内疚？或者为什么他们在战争结束时如此迅速地抛弃了他们为之奋斗的原则？我知道奴隶制已经被废除了，但为什么他们不继续说废除奴隶制是一种耻辱呢？奴隶制很棒。我的意思是，为什么他们不提出这个论点？他们中的一些人确实提出了这个论点，不是说废除奴隶制是一种耻辱，而是说这难道不是一件令人悲伤的事情吗？你知道，就像契诃夫的戏剧中对农奴制时代有一种怀旧之情，这种观念认为，实际上事情要稳定得多，
everybody knew where they were and And fundamentally, everybody was happier. So there is that part of it. And I think that, you know, that continues long into the 20th, probably into the 21st century, this lingering sense that actually maybe slavery really, you know, we would have been better if we'd kept it. But it was alongside this kind of tacit acceptance that, well, you know, look, it's gone everywhere else in the world. And that this is not a hill anymore on which it's possible to die, even if they wanted to. And of course, what they definitely don't do is to move away from their commitment to maintaining white home rule or white supremacy in the southern states. In fact, they remain as committed to that as ever. So the line in the South in the immediate aftermath of the war is, okay, well, we will grudgingly, reluctantly accept that our bid for independence
每个人都知道自己的位置，从根本上说，每个人都更快乐。所以这部分确实存在。我认为，这一直持续到20世纪，可能一直持续到21世纪，这种挥之不去的感触，即实际上也许奴隶制真的，你知道，如果我们保留它会更好。但这伴随着一种默许，即，好吧，你看，它在世界其他地方已经消失了。而且这不再是一个值得为之牺牲的阵地，即使他们想这样做。当然，他们绝对没有做的是放弃他们维持南方各州白人自治或白人至上的承诺。事实上，他们对此依然坚定不移。所以战争结束后，南方人的立场是，好吧，我们会勉强、不情愿地接受我们争取独立的尝试
is over. And we will even if we absolutely have to accept that slavery in the form that had existed up until now, looks like that's gone as well. It has been a devastating experience for all of us. We've all lost thousands of dollars of property, including our property and human beings. But what we absolutely will not do is to knuckle under the yoke of the Yankee radical Jacobins who have now taken power in Washington. And so we will not cede our right to control racial affairs in the South. And on that, they do not yield and they win for generations. Okay. So we'll come to the implications of that in a minute, but you
已经结束了。我们甚至会，如果我们绝对必须接受的话，接受奴隶制以迄今为止存在的那种形式，看起来也已经消失了。这对我们所有人来说都是一次毁灭性的经历。我们都损失了数千美元的财产，包括我们作为人类的财产。但我们绝对不会做的是屈服于现在在华盛顿掌权的北方激进雅各宾派的枷锁之下。因此，我们不会放弃我们在南方控制种族事务的权利。在这一点上，他们没有让步，并且赢得了几代人的时间。好的。那么我们稍后再谈其影响，但你
mentioned the radical Yankee Jacobins in Washington. And of course, there is one particular radical Jacobin Yankee in Washington, who dies almost immediately. And that, of course, is Abraham Lincoln. And what is the impact of that? And he is shot in a theatre, unfortunately, for clergymen. It's unfortunate unfortunate it's in a theater but it's on good friday 1865 he actually dies early the next morning so the sermons write themselves right that sunday as the news spreads around the union that abraham lincoln has sacrificed his life that the union might live and he's literally been shot by an actor by somebody john wilkes booth an actor because he had said talked about giving black men the right to vote
提到了华盛顿的激进北方雅各宾派。当然，华盛顿有一位特别的激进雅各宾派北方人，他几乎立即就去世了。那当然就是亚伯拉罕·林肯。那有什么影响呢？他不幸在剧院被枪杀，对于神职人员来说。不幸的是，它发生在剧院，但那是在1865年的耶稣受难日，他实际上在第二天清晨去世了，所以布道词自己就写好了，对吧？那个星期天，当亚伯拉罕·林肯为了联邦能够生存而牺牲了自己的生命的消息在联邦中传播开来时，他确实是被一名演员，约翰·威尔克斯·布斯，一名演员枪杀的，因为他曾谈到给予黑人投票权。
that's right isn't it yes that's almost certainly the case um i mean booth was in the crowd when lincoln gave his last public address as it's called in which he speculated about giving black people the vote and booth um who lincoln had seen perform was a well-known shakespearean actor part of a well-known acting family um booth felt himself to be um the instrument of god in doing god's work in in killing the the tyrant lincoln so it's an extraordinary end to the war i mean it's as though you know churchill was shot within moments of um of hitler's suicide in his bunker or something because it it means at the end of the war has this kind of very bittersweet yeah elegiac quality But it also raises this question. Well, what's good?
那是对的，不是吗？是的，这几乎肯定是事实。我的意思是，布斯在林肯发表最后一次公开演讲时就在人群中，林肯在演讲中推测给予黑人投票权，而布斯——林肯曾看过他的表演——是一位著名的莎士比亚演员，来自一个著名的演艺家庭。布斯认为自己是上帝的工具，在做上帝的工作，杀死了暴君林肯。所以这是战争的一个非凡结局。我的意思是，就好像丘吉尔在希特勒在地堡自杀后不久就被枪杀了一样，或者类似的事情，因为它意味着战争结束时有一种非常苦乐参半的、挽歌般的特质。但这也提出了一个问题。好吧，什么是好的？
I mean, you mentioned, you said already the South win. Yeah, they win their bid for racial control. They win that bit of it. Yeah, they win in that sense. So had Lincoln, I mean, does Lincoln's death make any difference? Or are we overemphasizing the importance of Warren as, in a vertical, as great man? I'm sure it does make a difference. But, you know but I really don't know in the end what difference it would have made. I mean, I can't help but feel that it does. It did matter because Lincoln had a political dexterity, an understanding of how to work with Congress, and a vastly greater ability to channel public opinion, to lead public opinion than his
我的意思是，你提到了，你已经说过南方赢了。是的，他们赢得了种族控制权的争夺。他们赢得了那一部分。是的，他们在那种意义上赢了。那么林肯的死有什么区别吗？还是我们过分强调了伟人作为历史转折点的重要性？我相信这确实有区别。但是，你知道，我最终真的不知道会有什么不同。我的意思是，我禁不住觉得这确实很重要，因为林肯有一种政治灵活性，一种理解如何与国会合作的洞察力，以及一种比他的
successor, Andrew Johnson, ever had in spades. I mean, there's just no comparison. But that said, exactly what would Lincoln have done differently? That is, of course, where it becomes very difficult to say, because in the end, he would have been dealing with the same set of challenges as Andrew Johnson was facing, with the same set of incompatible demands of on the one hand, white southerners saying, well, look, if you want to maintain stability, if you want to maintain national security and prevent the recurrence of this rebellion, then you have to do business with us. Sorry, just to turn Dominic's question on the head. I mean, is there not another way of framing it, which is to say the fact that Lincoln dies immediately after the war, and before he can kind
继任者安德鲁·约翰逊所拥有的远为强大的引导公众舆论、领导公众舆论的能力。我的意思是，根本无法比较。但话虽如此，林肯到底会做些什么不同的事情呢？这当然是很难说的地方，因为最终，他将不得不处理与安德鲁·约翰逊所面临的同样的一系列挑战，面对同样的一系列不相容的要求：一方面，白人南方人说，好吧，看，如果你想维持稳定，如果你想维持国家安全并防止这种叛乱的再次发生，那么你就必须与我们做生意。抱歉，只是想把多米尼克的问题反过来问。我的意思是，难道没有另一种框架方式吗？那就是说，林肯在战争结束后立即去世，在他能够以某种方式
of dirty his hands with muddy compromises, means that in the long run, he can serve as a symbol of everything that is best about America, everything that is noblest about America, kind of uncorrupted by the grubby compromises he might otherwise have had to make. Oh, unquestionably. If the question is about Lincoln's image, that's undoubtedly true. Can I read a bit of Whitman? Do, go for it. Because I was going to use this and then Dominic insisted in crowbarring his... I don't think crowbarring is the word. No, I think you absolutely did. You complained about being cut off at the end of the previous episode meaning that we couldn't have some walt whitman so this is uh will be familiar to to uh all fans of dead pert society oh captain
弄脏他的手进行肮脏的妥协之前，意味着从长远来看，他可以作为一个象征，代表美国最好的一切，美国最高尚的一切，而不被他本可能不得不做的肮脏妥协所腐蚀。哦，毫无疑问。如果问题是关于林肯的形象，那无疑是真的。我可以读一点惠特曼的作品吗？去吧，读吧。因为我本来打算用这个，然后多米尼克坚持要强行插入他的……我不认为“强行插入”是这个词。不，我认为你绝对是这样做的。你抱怨在上一集结尾被打断，意味着我们不能读一些沃尔特·惠特曼的作品，所以这对于所有《死亡诗社》的粉丝来说都会很熟悉，哦，船长，
my captain our fearful trip is done the ship has weathered every rack the prize we sought is won the port is near the bells i hear the people all exulting. While follow eyes the steady keel, the vessel grim and daring. But oh heart, heart, heart, oh the bleeding drops of red. Where on the deck my captain lies, fallen, cold and dead. It's like listening to Robin Williams. Similarly inspirational. I mean, just one of the kind of amazing sequence of poems that whitman wrote over that year of 1865 um kind of halloween i mean you know and the fact that he dies on good
我的船长，我们可怕的航程已经结束。这艘船经受住了每一次风暴，我们寻求的奖赏已经赢得。港口就在眼前，我听到了钟声，人们都在欢呼。当眼睛跟随那稳健的龙骨，那艘冷酷而大胆的船只。但哦，心，心，心，哦，那流血的红色水滴。我的船长倒在甲板上，冰冷而死。这就像在听罗宾·威廉姆斯。同样具有启发性。我的意思是，这只是惠特曼在1865年那一年写的一系列惊人诗歌中的一首，嗯，某种万圣节，我的意思是，你知道，他死在耶稣受难日的事实，
friday i mean as you say i mean it enshrines lincoln as this great emblem of liberty i agree with you tom that absolutely his death absolutely enshrines him as this uncorrupted figure because it's i mean okay so adam you may completely disagree with me but my view would be the north is in an impossible position at the end of the the war because to to force the white south to to completely redraw their their arrangements but also their kind of their assumptions, their intellectual and cultural assumptions about their new black neighbors would require presumably keeping an army in the South for 10 years, 20 years? Because, I mean, they quite quickly are facing clan paramilitary violence to try and retake control for the old Southern elite. So do you think, I mean, the North's heart was never in that, was it?
我的意思是，正如你所说，它将林肯奉为自由的伟大象征。我同意你的观点，汤姆，他的死绝对将他塑造成一个未受腐蚀的人物，因为我的意思是，好吧，亚当，你可能完全不同意我的观点，但我的看法是，战争结束时，北方处于一种不可能的境地，因为要强迫白人南方人彻底重绘他们的安排，以及他们对新黑人邻居的假设、智力和文化假设，大概需要长期在南方驻军10年、20年？因为，我的意思是，他们很快就面临着三K党准军事暴力，试图为旧南方精英夺回控制权。所以你认为，我的意思是，北方的内心从来没有在那上面，对吧？
No, I don't disagree. On the contrary, I strongly agree with you. I think probably most other historians writing about this at the moment would disagree with us both. So what would they think, though? What's their case, right? Well, the way in which Reconstruction, this period after the Civil War, is usually written about is as a kind of disgraceful, head-shaking series of missed opportunities. And if it only went for the supine nature of the individual people and of the northern public at certain moments, then maybe, maybe, maybe something greater could have been achieved and a biracial democracy could have been properly established.
不，我不同意。相反，我强烈同意你的观点。我认为目前写这个主题的大多数其他历史学家都会不同意我们两人的观点。那么他们会怎么想呢？他们的论点是什么？嗯，重建，即内战后的这段时期，通常被描述为一系列可耻的、令人摇头叹息的错失良机。如果只是因为个人和北方公众在某些时刻的软弱，那么也许，也许，也许可以取得更大的成就，并可以适当地建立一个多种族的民主国家。
But I completely agree with you, Dominic. I don't think that was ever going to happen. And I think the thing was in 1865, northerners, they'd done the job. There wasn't anything else to do really for most of them because they'd secured the union. The only thing they were really, really concerned about were any future dangers to the union. And so reconstruction for most northerners, not for the, there were always, there were radical Republicans who were completely and genuinely and sincerely committed to equal
但我完全同意你的观点，多米尼克。我不认为那会发生。我认为1865年的情况是，北方人已经完成了工作。对于他们大多数人来说，真的没有什么别的事情可做了，因为他们已经确保了联邦的安全。他们真正关心的唯一事情是联邦面临的任何未来危险。所以对于大多数北方人来说，重建，而不是对于那些，总是有激进的共和党人，他们完全、真诚地致力于非裔美国人的平等
citizenship for African American people. And they won some stunning political successes. Most of all, the passage of the 14th Amendment, which states exactly what I've just said, which grants citizenship to black people or everybody born in the United States, and therefore including black people, and then gives them equal rights under the law on paper, on parchment. But that was an amazing radical success. In my view, the great majority of white northerners were never that bothered about any of that. What they didn't want to have to do was to fight another war. They didn't want white enslavers, the slave power, lording it over them over again. They were quite
公民身份。他们取得了一些惊人的政治成功。最重要的是，第14修正案的通过，它准确地陈述了我刚才所说的，它赋予黑人或在美国出生的每个人公民身份，因此包括黑人，然后在纸面上、在羊皮纸上赋予他们法律面前的平等权利。但这确实是一个惊人的激进成功。在我看来，绝大多数白人北方人从来没有那么在意这些。他们不想做的是打另一场战争。他们不想让白人奴隶主，即奴隶主势力，再次骑在他们头上作威作福。他们很高兴
happy to see the South impoverished and marginalized. But they, in the end, were not that bothered about the idea of the South controlling their own racial order, because after all, that's what they wanted to do back home in the North as well. And, you know, it's one thing to be enfranchising, you could genuinely think in Massachusetts as a Republican, yes, let's enfranchise black people in South Carolina, if that helps to prop up the Republican Party in South Carolina and keeps those rebels out of power for a bit longer. But hang on, don't tell me that I've got to enfranchise Irish immigrants as soon as they walk off the boat. I want the right to regulate the franchise here in Massachusetts of people I don't like. So they wanted to control who took part in the polity, just as Southerners did. And is there also the case that history starts, you know, the conveyor belt starts moving again and American expansion happens?
看到南方贫困和边缘化。但他们最终并不太在意南方控制其自身种族秩序的想法，因为毕竟，这也是他们在北方老家想要做的事情。而且，你知道，在马萨诸塞州作为一个共和党人，你可以真诚地认为，是的，让我们赋予南卡罗来纳州的黑人选举权，如果这有助于支持南卡罗来纳州的共和党，并让那些叛军在权力之外多待一会儿，这是一回事。但是等等，别告诉我我必须在爱尔兰移民刚下船时就赋予他们选举权。我想在马萨诸塞州这里监管我不喜欢的人的选举权。所以他们想控制谁参与政治，就像南方人一样。而且是否还有这样一种情况，历史开始，你知道，传送带又开始移动了，美国扩张发生了？
And suddenly what's happened in this narrow strip of land between Richmond and Washington suddenly seems rather peripheral compared to the vast expanses of the West and manifest destiny and things like that. And that people, you know, their focus. They want to make money. Opportunities to make money opportunities to make money the gilded age everything's turning and suddenly this is yesterday's history let's leave them in their kind of backwards i think i wouldn't i i agree with the with the with the gist of what you're saying i i don't think it it made what happened between richmond and and washington peripheral i think it made it to quote a mid-20th century scholar,
突然之间，在里士满和华盛顿之间这片狭长地带发生的事情，与广阔的西部和天命论等相比，似乎显得相当边缘化了。人们，你知道，他们的焦点。他们想赚钱。赚钱的机会，赚钱的机会，镀金时代，一切都在转变，突然之间这成了昨天的历史，让我们把他们留在那种落后的状态。我想我不会，我同意你所说的要点，我不认为这使得里士满和华盛顿之间发生的事情变得边缘化，我认为这使得它，引用一位20世纪中叶学者的话，
a kind of treasury of virtue, something that they could return to. Right. Wonderful stories that made them feel good about themselves as a nation because, after all, they just, you know, just as the British had been self-congratulating themselves since the 1830s for having abolished slavery, now the Americans could do it, but they had died in order to end slavery and to remove the sin of slavery from the nationalist scutcheon there we are have you ever heard the
一种美德的宝库，他们可以回归的东西。对，美妙的故事让他们作为一个国家对自己感觉良好，因为毕竟，他们只是，你知道，就像英国人自1830年代以来一直为废除奴隶制而自我祝贺一样，现在美国人也可以这样做，但他们已经牺牲了生命来结束奴隶制，并从民族的盾徽上抹去了奴隶制的罪恶。我们到了。你以前在这个节目中听过
word escutcheon in this program before you probably have uh i think this is quite an escutcheon heavy podcast yeah this is um i think when we come back we should look at how the civil war is is understood now but just just to pick up on that idea of it providing mythology, would there be a case for saying that in a way the mythology is perhaps the most important legacy? And there are two myths. There's the myth of the lost cause, romantic cavaliers, all that kind of stuff. And there's the myth that is kind of sanctified by Lincoln's assassination of a virtuous, freedom-loving people who have sacrificed, you know, not just their president, but the lives of their sons
“盾徽”（escutcheon）这个词吗？你可能听过，我想这是一个盾徽很重的播客。是的，这是，我想当我们回来时，我们应该看看内战现在是如何被理解的，但只是为了拾起它提供神话的那个想法，是否有理由说，在某种程度上，神话也许是最重要的遗产？有两个神话。一个是“迷途事业”的神话，浪漫的骑士，所有那种东西。另一个是林肯遇刺所神圣化的神话，即一个善良、热爱自由的人民，他们牺牲了，你知道，不仅是他们的总统，还有他们儿子的生命
and fathers and brothers on the cause of liberty and racial equality. And that both of those two myths feeding into the 20th century are still kind of reverberating into the 21st century. Absolutely. Brilliantly put. Okay. Well, fabulous. On that note, let's go to a commercial break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
以及父亲和兄弟，为了自由和平等的崇高事业。这两个神话都流入了20世纪，并且仍然在21世纪产生回响。绝对是。说得太棒了。好的，太棒了。在那一点上，让我们进入商业广告时间。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain
我们共同主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开帷幕，
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, everybody. Now, regular listeners will know that from time to time, we like to talk about an article from UnHerdheard the online magazine for which both of us have written and which kindly sponsors the rest is
揭示娱乐业的内幕，并告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好。现在，常客们会知道，我们不时喜欢谈论《UnHerd》杂志上的一篇文章，这是我们两人都为其撰稿的在线杂志，它也慷慨地赞助了《历史的余味》，
history and this week it's a very striking piece by their staff writer will lloyd very good writer and it's called how to fly a spitfire and will describes the final gathering of project propeller which is the annual get-together of Royal Air Force veterans from the Second World War. There's only a few of them left, and it's meeting this year for the very last time, or probably the very last time anyway. People are exquisitely careful with them, Will writes, utterly decorous and graceful. They're so valuable, and there are so few of them left. It's as if we're in a room with Henry's longbowmen or Nelson's sailors. Our scope for reverence, usually so limited, is much larger here. And Will goes on to describe the extraordinary moment when Bill Williams, a 101-year-old veteran, is handed the controls of a Cessna mid-flight and allowed to fly once again. It feels heavier
本周有一篇由他们的特约撰稿人威尔·劳埃德撰写的非常引人注目的文章，他是一位非常优秀的作家，题目是《如何驾驶喷火战斗机》。威尔描述了“螺旋桨计划”的最后一次聚会，这是二战英国皇家空军老兵的年度聚会。他们只剩下几个人了，今年是最后一次聚会，或者至少可能是最后一次。威尔写道，人们对他们极其小心，完全庄重而优雅。他们太宝贵了，而且所剩无几。就好像我们正与亨利的弓箭手或纳尔逊的水手们共处一室。我们通常如此有限的敬畏空间，在这里要大得多。威尔接着描述了非凡的一刻，101岁的老兵比尔·威廉姆斯在飞行中被移交了塞斯纳飞机的控制权，并被允许再次飞行。它感觉比
than a spitfire, he mutters to himself in the headset. He's attentive, composed, professional. Bill flew a thousand hours in the war. Suddenly a man who cannot walk has his wings back. I watch him closely, everyone in the plane does. Bill looks younger, visibly freshened. He's twenty again, avoiding purple-black monsoon clouds above a Burmese delta. He's not flying. He's travelling back in time. There's only one thing it makes sense to ask him. How does it feel to be back? Oh. He pauses, searching for the right word. It's wonderful. Now, Unheard publishes lots of original long reads like this, and it tackles politics and all kinds of world issues through the lens of history and philosophy every day. It's normally
喷火战斗机更重，他在耳机里喃喃自语。他专注、沉着、专业。比尔在战争中飞行了一千个小时。突然，一个无法行走的人找回了他的翅膀。我仔细观察他，飞机上的每个人都这样。比尔看起来更年轻，明显焕然一新。他又回到了二十岁，避开缅甸三角洲上空的紫黑色季风云。他不是在飞行。他是在穿越回过去。问他一个问题是有意义的。回到这里感觉如何？哦。他停顿了一下，寻找合适的词。这太美妙了。现在，《UnHerd》每天都会发布许多像这样的原创长篇阅读，它通过历史和哲学的视角来处理政治和各种世界问题。它通常
a pound a week, but you guessed it, there is a special offer for Rest Is History subscribers to try it out. So that means you will get the first three months free. And if you don't like it you can always cancel so go to unheard.com slash rest to check it out that's unheard.com slash rest welcome back to the rest is history now before we get more deeply into the way the the war itself is remembered um adam uh the war was followed by a period of reconstruction which you know certainly when i studied it at university the story of reconstruction was that it was a failure that black americans a generation or so later okay they weren't enslaved anymore but they were very much second-class citizens they were segregated all of these kinds
是一周一英镑，但你猜对了，有一个特别优惠给《历史的余味》订阅者来尝试一下。这意味着你将获得前三个月免费。如果你不喜欢，你总是可以取消，所以去 unheard.com/rest 查看一下，那是 unheard.com/rest。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在，在我们更深入地探讨战争本身被记忆的方式之前，嗯，亚当，战争之后是一段重建时期，你知道，当然当我还在大学学习时，重建的故事是它是一个失败，非裔美国人在一代人左右之后，好吧，他们不再被奴役了，但他们确实是二等公民，他们被隔离，所有这些
of things is that basically how how most American historians think about Reconstruction now, as this sort of utter disaster and sort of tragedy? Or do they see some good in it, or do they think it was inevitable, or what? Because obviously now, in the 21st century, these things have incendiary kind of political meanings, don't they? I think it's not so much that it was a tragedy, but that there were missed opportunities, that it was an unfinished revolution. And some of the things that happened in Reconstruction were crucial to advances that were later made towards racial justice. So the 14th Amendment, which puts into
事情，这基本上是大多数美国历史学家现在对重建的看法吗，认为这是一场彻底的灾难和某种悲剧？还是他们从中看到了一些好处，或者他们认为这是不可避免的，或者什么？因为显然现在，在21世纪，这些事情具有煽动性的政治含义，不是吗？我认为与其说这是一场悲剧，不如说是有错失的良机，这是一场未完成的革命。重建中发生的一些事情对于后来在种族正义方面取得的进展至关重要。所以第14修正案，它把
the Constitution for the first time, defined citizenship for the first time, and in such a way as to include African Americans, even though the 14th Amendment was disregarded or violated in practice for decades and decades after it was passed, was nevertheless there in the Constitution as something that could be invoked and was invoked by Martin Luther King. If we are wrong, then the Constitution of the United States is wrong, King said in the 1950s, referring not really to the original Constitution of 1787, but to the 14th Amendment, which was passed in the wake of the American Civil War and as a direct result of it. So in that sense, what happened after the
公民身份第一次定义在宪法中，并且以一种包括非裔美国人的方式，尽管第14修正案在通过后的几十年里在实践中被忽视或违反，但它仍然存在于宪法中，作为可以被援引的东西，并且被马丁·路德·金援引过。如果我们错了，那么美国宪法就错了，金在1950年代说，指的并不是1787年的原始宪法，而是第14修正案，它是在美国内战之后作为直接结果通过的。所以从这个意义上说，发生的事情在
Civil War is of huge consequence, even though the condition of African American people by the end of the 19th century was dire by any measure. They were completely marginalized within Southern society. They were subjected to systematic violence in the form of lynching and other forms of intimidation and violent action. They were in practice denied the right to vote, even though they theoretically had it. They were excluded from jury service and in practice from much property ownership and lived on the margins of white society and, of course, continued to do so for long into the 20th century and beyond. And in the 21st century, because when you began your career looking at this period,
内战之后具有巨大的后果，尽管到19世纪末，非裔美国人的状况无论从什么标准来看都是可怕的。他们在南方社会中被完全边缘化。他们遭受了以私刑和其他形式的恐吓和暴力行为为形式的系统性暴力。他们在实践中被剥夺了投票权，尽管他们在理论上拥有它。他们被排除在陪审团服务之外，在实践中被排除在大部分财产所有权之外，生活在白人社会的边缘，当然，在20世纪及以后很长一段时间里继续这样做。而在21世纪，因为当你开始你的职业生涯研究这个时期时，
specialising in this period, did you have a sense of it becoming kind of ever more politically combustible as an issue within contemporary United States? So 20 years ago, or so, more than that, when I first started studying this period, it seemed it was possible for me, especially perhaps as a British person, to study the American Civil War in much the way that I might have studied the English Civil War. There were a set of fascinating interlocking intellectual problems that I wanted to understand. It didn't really feel back then in the 90s, in that kind of Clinton era, as if what I was dealing with was live American politics,
专门研究这个时期，你是否感觉到它在当代美国成为一个越来越具有政治爆炸性的问题？所以20年前，或者左右，更多一点，当我第一次开始研究这个时期时，对我来说，特别是作为一个英国人，似乎有可能以我研究英国内战的方式来研究美国内战。有一系列迷人的相互交织的智力问题，我想理解。在90年代，在那种克林顿时代，感觉并不像是我在处理活生生的美国政治，
even though it obviously was. And on some level, I must have known that. And I did know that, you know, you walk around the South, you drive around the South back then in the 90s, the number of Confederate monuments. And I remember being struck and kind of appalled and fascinated by the centrality of them all. But they weren't really a big political issue then, were they? And they've become so now, those monuments and everything else that's gone along with it. So have you been surprised by what's happened? Or did you have a sense that this was something that was going to happen? I can't really say that I had some amazing, prescient understanding that this was an issue that was going to explode exactly when it did.
尽管它显然是。在某种程度上，我一定知道这一点。我确实知道，你知道，你在90年代在南方走动，开车在南方，邦联纪念碑的数量。我记得被它们的中心地位所震撼，并感到震惊和着迷。但它们当时并不是一个大的政治问题，对吧？而现在它们已经变成了这样，那些纪念碑以及随之而来的一切。所以你对发生的事情感到惊讶吗？还是你有一种感觉，这将会发生？我真的不能说我有一种惊人的、先见之明的理解，即这是一个会在它发生时就爆炸的问题。
But I suppose on some level, yes. And I suppose everybody else studying the American Civil War realized that it was unfinished business. There was never a sense, even at the end of the 20th century, when I got into this world, that this was entirely settled history. It's just that it was sleeping history then. So there's a great question here from Lindsay Hopkins, who asks, how can contemporary historians approach the subject and analyze the evidence without bias or preconceptions, while the issues surrounding the conflict remain so viscerally alive in American culture? I mean, I guess that's a question that all historians, you know, we're all influenced by the context in which we work and by our assumptions and biases and so on. But it does seem, I mean, writing about the Civil War at the moment must be like sitting in the library while there's a kind of blazing fire all around it. Yeah, it does feel like that. And actually, I mean, you probably don't want to get into this,
但我认为在某种程度上，是的。我想研究美国内战的每个人都意识到这是未完成的事业。即使在我进入这个世界的20世纪末，也从来没有一种感觉，认为这是完全定论的历史。只是它当时是沉睡的历史。所以这里有一个来自林赛·霍普金斯的好问题，她问，当代历史学家如何在不带偏见或先入之见的情况下接近这个主题并分析证据，而围绕冲突的问题在美式文化中仍然如此生动地存在？我的意思是，我想那是所有历史学家的问题，你知道，我们都受到我们工作环境以及我们的假设和偏见等的影响。但它确实看起来，我的意思是，目前写关于内战的文章一定就像坐在图书馆里，而周围有一场大火。是的，感觉确实是这样。而且实际上，我的意思是，你可能不想深入探讨这个，
but actually not being in an American university, I think, is quite helpful. I can't say it's actually studying this from Oxford in some ways insulates me from that fire. I can see it happening across the Atlantic, but it's not actually really happening all around me. But no, I mean, yes, it is really hard and it's very difficult. There's large sections of the American population right now who are, you know, who feel real pain and a deep burning sense of injustice, which is directly and correctly connected to the experience of the 19th century. And it's kind of facile and irresponsible to kind of pretend that that isn't the reality.
但实际上不在美国大学，我认为是很有帮助的。我不能说从牛津研究这个在某些方面使我免受那场火灾的影响。我可以看到它在大西洋彼岸发生，但它并没有真正发生在我周围。但不，我的意思是，是的，这确实很难，而且非常困难。目前有很大一部分美国人口，你知道，他们感到真正的痛苦和一种深刻的、燃烧的不公正感，这与19世纪的经历直接且正确地联系在一起。假装那不是现实，这是一种肤浅和不负责任的行为。
That the battles that we've been talking about in these podcasts are still being fought out. And that the question of who controls, who rules at home, who are the members of this polity who get to decide what are the rules of the game, those are the battles of American history from before the Civil War, and they're still the battles of America today. And so those of us who work in the Civil War era are writing about issues which are of direct and immediate relevance. How do you do that without being, which you can't do it. I mean, as you say, Tom, I mean, you can't, when you write about anything as a? Which you can't do it. I mean, as you say, Tom, I mean, you can't when you write about anything as a historian, you can't but be influenced by the present.
我们在这些播客中谈论的战斗仍在继续。关于谁控制、谁在家中统治、谁是这个政治体中决定游戏规则的成员的问题，这些是内战前的美国历史的战斗，它们仍然是今天美国的战斗。所以我们这些在内战时代工作的人正在撰写具有直接和即时相关性的问题。你如何做到这一点而不被，你做不到。我的意思是，正如你所说，汤姆，我的意思是，你不能，当你写任何东西作为？你做不到。我的意思是，正如你所说，汤姆，我的意思是，当你作为历史学家写任何东西时，你不可能不受到现在的影响。
At least what I try to do in my work is to always try to understand how political ideas and concepts and terms are used, were used at the time by the people using them. And that can be a very difficult thing to do when you know that there are issues being discussed in the past that seem on the surface and often are in reality so similar to those being discussed today and yet often the assumptions that go into the judgments being made by people at the time are different from the ones that people made today and so it's a question of historical reconstruction to try to get ourselves into the minds of the people and to understand the pastness of the past, even though we're also understanding its connectedness to the present. But Adam, that thing about understanding the
至少我在我的工作中尝试做的是，总是尝试理解政治思想、概念和术语在当时被使用它们的人是如何使用的。当你意识到过去正在讨论的问题在表面上看起来，而且往往在现实中确实与今天正在讨论的问题如此相似，但往往当时人们所做的判断所包含的假设与今天人们所做的假设不同时，这可能是一件非常困难的事情。所以这是一个历史重建的问题，试图让我们进入人们的思想，并理解过去的过去性，尽管我们也理解它与现在的联系。但亚当，关于理解
pastness of the past, I mean, obviously, all historians try to do that, as you say, but you raised an interesting comparison with the English Civil War, or the British Civil Wars, as they're now called. So that period has always had a lot of political baggage. You know, Marxists were very interested in the civil wars of the 17th century and still are. And, you know, the sort of Christopher Hill, all the arguments about the Levellers and Oliver Cromwell and stuff, that was all great fun.
过去的过去性，我的意思是，显然，所有历史学家都试图这样做，正如你所说，但你提出了一个与英国内战，或者现在被称为英国国内战争的有趣的比较。所以那个时期一直有很多政治包袱。你知道，马克思主义者对17世纪的内战非常感兴趣，现在仍然如此。而且，你知道，克里斯托弗·希尔，关于平等派和奥利弗·克伦威尔等人的所有争论，那都非常有趣。
It was all great historiographical fun in kind of post-war Britain. It didn't remotely have the charge that the American Civil War. I mean, maybe the closest that it comes is what Cromwell did in Ireland. Maybe, but I don't think that's... I mean, I know not remotely, but that is a vivid and alive issue, perhaps. Maybe that's as close as you get. But do you think in our lifetime, historians will ever be able to write about this? Will they ever get to a point
在战后的英国，这都是非常有趣的史学乐趣。它根本没有美国内战的那种冲击力。我的意思是，也许最接近的是克伦威尔在爱尔兰所做的事情。也许，但我认为那不是……我的意思是，我知道不完全是，但那是一个生动且活跃的问题，也许。也许那是你所能达到的最接近的程度。但你认为在我们有生之年，历史学家是否能够写出这个？他们是否会达到一个点
where they're writing about this period, about abolition, about slavery and reconstruction, with the same degree of distance, almost emotional distance, I suppose, the psychological distance that we in Britain have with our own civil war? Or do you think the... I mean
他们写这个时期，关于废奴，关于奴隶制和重建，具有同样的距离感，几乎是情感距离，我想，心理距离，我们英国人对自己内战所拥有的那种距离感？或者你认为……我的意思是
I suppose you'd only get to that point when those issues are settled wouldn't you and they're not going to be settled now yeah now the answer to the question is no I don't because I don't think in our lifetimes in my lifetime anyway um I I don't imagine that these issues of racial justice in the United States are going to be resolved in a way that will enable that people to write in that with that kind of tone no and so so long as race is still a central issue in america and it will always be the civil war will still be a live question and can i ask um the way i mean not just the weight the totality of liberal opinion is obviously very strongly of the opinion that the union was in the right and that the right side won in the civil war within america what's the balance of sympathy with the confederacy with
我想你只有在这些问题得到解决时才会达到那个点，不是吗？而它们现在不会得到解决。是的，现在问题的答案是不，我没有，因为我不认为在我们有生之年，无论如何在我有生之年，嗯，我不认为美国这些种族正义的问题会以一种使人们能够以那种语气写作的方式得到解决，不。所以只要种族仍然是美国的一个核心问题，而且它将永远是，内战仍然是一个活跃的问题。我可以问，嗯，我的意思是，不仅仅是自由派舆论的权重显然非常强烈地认为联邦是正确的，并且正确的一方赢得了美国内战，对邦联的同情平衡是什么，
the kind of the myths that it has the the ideals that it has articulated and so on um because i i find it hard to get a sense a handle on. I think that the kind of brilliance of the neo-Confederate operation over 150 years has been that it has meant that it is possible, and it is still possible, to literally hold a Confederate flag in one hand and a United States flag in the other. You can embrace the values of the Confederacy. It's our heritage. It's our history. They're our ancestors. They were fighting for real American ideals and yet somehow conveniently ignore the fact that they were traitors, that they were rebels. Yeah.
它所拥有的那种神话，它所阐述的理想等等，嗯，因为我发现很难得到一个感觉，一个把手。我认为新邦联行动在150年来的那种辉煌在于，它意味着有可能，而且仍然有可能，字面上在一只手中拿着邦联旗帜，在另一只手中拿着美国国旗。你可以拥抱邦联的价值观。这是我们的遗产。这是我们的历史。他们是我们的祖先。他们为真正的美国理想而战，但不知何故方便地忽略了他们是叛徒，他们是叛军的事实。是的。
But it is because they were the continuity USA. I mean, that was what the Confederates themselves were doing. They were trying to create a separate Confederacy, but they were trying to do it in the name of the original revolution of 1776. Well, Adam, I came across this amazing detail, which I didn't know, but it turned out that loads of experts in submarines knew, that in the 50s, when the US Navy launched a fleet of ballistic missile submarines, the USS Robert E. Lee was the third commissioned. And the first was the George Washington, the second was the Patrick Henry,
但这是因为他们是美国连续性的体现。我的意思是，这正是邦联人自己所做的。他们试图建立一个独立的邦联，但他们试图以1776年原始革命的名义来做这件事。嗯，亚当，我偶然发现了一个惊人的细节，我以前不知道，但事实证明，许多潜艇专家都知道，在50年代，当美国海军发射了一支弹道导弹潜艇舰队时，罗伯特·E·李号是第三艘服役的。第一艘是乔治·华盛顿号，第二艘是帕特里克·亨利号，
and the fourth was the Abraham Lincoln. So Lee gave his name to a US Navy submarine before Lincoln. That presumably would not happen now. Well, it wouldn't happen right now. Right now, I mean, of course, there's been a commission, which is, I think, as we're recording, just about to report on renaming Confederate bases, of which, you know, there are hundreds of not just bases, but other kinds of military installations and ships and so on that are named after Confederates, mostly military figures. There's a huge portrait of Robert E. Lee in West Point. And so what's the balance of opinion on that, though? Well, I think things have tipped, but very recently. And I think it's been the reaction
第四艘是亚伯拉罕·林肯号。所以李在林肯之前就以他的名字命名了一艘美国海军潜艇。这在现在大概不会发生了。嗯，现在确实不会发生了。我的意思是，当然，有一个委员会，我想，在我们录制的时候，即将报告关于重命名邦联基地的问题，你知道，有数百个不仅是基地，还有其他类型的军事设施和船只等等，都是以邦联人物命名的，主要是军事人物。西点军校里有一幅巨大的罗伯特·E·李的肖像。那么，对此的舆论平衡是什么呢？嗯，我认为情况已经发生了倾斜，但就在最近。我认为这是反应，
to the Trump presidency. So Trump is the president who has most overtly championed Confederate causes, well ever certainly since the civil war but he might win the next election he might so so presumably there's still a substantial support for this perspective yeah clearly clearly because i was i was i was struck listen i i thought i should get myself in the mood by um you know play before this podcast by playing some suitable music. So I played the famous Joan Baez song, what was it, The Day They Drove Old Dixie Down, which I hadn't listened to for years. And it never particularly struck me as problematic, as one might say.
对特朗普总统任期的反应。所以特朗普是自内战以来最公开支持邦联事业的总统，当然，但他可能会赢得下一次选举，他可能会，所以大概对这种观点仍然有相当大的支持，是的，显然，显然，因为我被震撼了，听着，我想我应该通过在播客之前播放一些合适的音乐来让自己进入状态。所以我播放了琼·贝兹那首著名的歌，叫什么来着，《他们把老迪克西降下的那一天》，我已经好几年没听了。它从来没有让我觉得有什么问题，就像人们可能说的那样。
But Tom, I mean, you merely have to, I mean, even growing up in Britain in the 1970s, I've mentioned before about history books showing Confederates as cavaliers. I mean, you think you would have grown up seeing the Dukes of Hazzard, seeing the Confederate flag on the car, you know, the General Lee car. You would have grown up, you know, with, I don't know, is it Lynyrd Skynyrd? With kind of music that, pop music, rock music that um exalts the south and the idea of the south is special um that it has a distinct history a history of sort of courtesy and gentility and tradition and all of these kinds of things and of course that often is not explicitly linked to the lost cause or to the civil war but it's always there isn't it adam hanging in the background do you think yeah and so that that's why it's always there, isn't it, Adam, hanging in the background,
但是汤姆，我的意思是，你只需要，我的意思是，即使是在20世纪70年代的英国长大，我之前提到过历史书把邦联人描绘成骑士。我的意思是，你会认为你在成长过程中看过《杜克兄弟》，看到车上的邦联旗，你知道，李将军那辆车。你会成长在，我不知道，是林纳·史金纳乐队吗？那种音乐，流行音乐，摇滚音乐，赞美南方，认为南方是特别的，它有着独特的历史，一种礼貌、绅士风度和传统的历史，所有这些东西，当然，这通常并没有明确地与“迷途事业”或内战联系起来，但它一直都在那里，不是吗，亚当，悬在背景中，你觉得呢？是的，所以这就是为什么它一直都在那里，不是吗，亚当，悬在背景中，
do you think? Yeah. And so that's why it's so difficult to answer Tom's question about the balance here. Because I think probably for most people, for most Americans, the two things are so hard to unpick. You know, at least until quite recently, even people who would regard themselves as, you know, extremely liberal and racially egalitarian would have, let's just say, a sneaking admiration for Stonewall Jackson, right? Or for Robert E. Lee, you would have a portrait, have a little postcard of him on their bookshelf, you know, and why not? What harm can it possibly do? And so what's happened really in the just the last few years has been this new kind of militant neo-abolitionism, where they they are saying just as people in the 1860s said
你觉得呢？是的。所以这就是为什么回答汤姆关于这里的平衡的问题如此困难。因为我认为对于大多数人，对于大多数美国人来说，这两件事很难分开。你知道，至少直到最近，即使是那些自认为是极其自由派和种族平等主义者的人，也会对石墙杰克逊有某种暗暗的钦佩，对吧？或者对罗伯特·E·李，你会有一幅肖像，在书架上放一张他的小明信片，你知道，为什么不呢？这能有什么害处呢？所以，在过去几年里，真正发生的是这种新型的激进的新废奴主义，他们说，就像19世纪60年代的人所说的那样，
as radical republicans as frederick douglas said no let us not give them any quarter these people were racist and enslavers and they were traitors okay but adam so a question so so robert e lee was a slave owner and he seems to have fought he taken the side he did because he wanted to keep possession of the plantations and the slaves that they brought stable jackson slightly more ambivalent figure as far as i know didn't keep slaves uh didn't support slavery uh taught sunday school to black children but fought on the side of the confederacy so how is how is he that's a very fine distinction that i well i know i mean it's an important distinction historically but i think in terms of this point about the the
就像激进的共和党人弗雷德里克·道格拉斯所说的那样，不，让我们不要给他们任何宽恕，这些人是种族主义者和奴隶主，他们是叛徒。好吧，但是亚当，一个问题，所以罗伯特·E·李是一个奴隶主，他似乎参加了战斗，他站在了那一边，因为他想保持对种植园和他们带来的奴隶的占有。石墙杰克逊据我所知是一个稍微矛盾的人物，没有蓄奴，不支持奴隶制，教黑人孩子主日学，但站在了邦联一边，所以他是怎么，这是一个非常微妙的区别，我，我知道，我的意思是，这在历史上是一个重要的区别，但我认为就这一点而言，
lingering sense that the myth of the confederacy and the old south has become imbricated in the idea of america and what it is to be american then then I think that kind of Confederate chic, the admiration of these glamorous, fascinating Confederate, brave, talented Confederate leaders of whom Jackson is a prominent example, you know, it's all part and parcel of the same thing. Yeah. And it's also tied, I mean, because of course, in a way, the archetype of the dashing Confederate cavalier is someone who fought on the Union side, which is General Custer. Yes. Who likewise was kind of eulogized as a hero and now is similarly seen in kind of far more ambivalent terms.
关于邦联和旧南方的神话已经融入了美国的概念以及什么是美国人的挥之不去的感官，那么我认为那种“邦联时尚”，对这些迷人、引人入胜、勇敢、有才华的邦联领导人的钦佩，杰克逊就是一个突出的例子，你知道，这都是同一件事的一部分。是的。而且它也与此有关，我的意思是，因为当然，在某种程度上，潇洒的邦联骑士的原型是那些在联邦一边战斗的人，也就是卡斯特将军。是的。他同样被赞美为英雄，现在也被以更矛盾的眼光看待。
I mean, the thing is, though, Tom, surely, I mean, you know, even as a Briton, it would be very hard, even insisting stubbornly on one's outsider status, it would be hard, at the very least, to go into a bar in America full of black people and to say, oh, I've got a great admiration for Robert E. Lee, what a tremendous commander and all this don't you think i mean i think it would seem a monstrous thing to do to i mean a lot of people in america would say that's like going into a pub full of jews and saying actually rommel was a tremendous fellow well so that is the other that is the other great shadow that hangs over the whole story now that didn't say in the 1860s, is the experience of the Second World War and what the Nazis did. And that is another parallel that is often drawn. But a parallel would actually then turn that around, Tom.
我的意思是，问题是，汤姆，当然，我的意思是，你知道，即使作为一个英国人，也很难，即使固执地坚持自己的局外人身份，也很难，至少，走进一家满是黑人的美国酒吧，说，哦，我对罗伯特·E·李非常钦佩，多么了不起的指挥官，所有这些，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，我觉得这看起来是一件极其荒谬的事情。我的意思是，美国很多人会说，这就像走进一家满是犹太人的酒吧，说，其实隆美尔是个了不起的家伙。嗯，所以这就是另一个，这就是现在笼罩在整个故事上的另一个巨大的阴影，19世纪60年代没有说，那就是第二次世界大战的经历以及纳粹所做的事情。这也是经常被引用的另一个平行点。但一个平行点实际上会扭转这一点，汤姆。
I mean, I would agree with you, you made that parallel. But again, you wouldn't walk into a bar in Atlanta full of white people and say, your ancestors were a pack of Nazis. No. I mean, maybe bars aren't the place to have the newest discussions of the American Civil War, full stop. Just stop going to bars. Adam, is there a way through this?
我的意思是，我会同意你的观点，你做了那个平行比较。但同样，你不会走进亚特兰大一家满是白人的酒吧，说，你们的祖先是一群纳粹。不。我的意思是，也许酒吧不是进行美国内战最新讨论的地方，句号。别再去酒吧了。亚当，有办法解决这个问题吗？
Do you think that in – I mean, you said basically in our lifetime, no. Well, I don't think in our lifetime the Civil War is going to be something that can be written about with the same sense of distance that we can write about the Wars of the Roses. I think that was the sort of implication of your question. What we're already seeing, though, is the visibility of Confederate memorialization becoming more and more marginalized. We're pretty close to a situation now where you're not going to go around seeing Confederate monuments anywhere in the United States. There aren't going to be
你认为在——我的意思是，你基本上说在我们有生之年，不。嗯，我不认为在我们有生之年，内战会成为我们可以用我们书写玫瑰战争的那种距离感来书写的东西。我想这就是你问题的含义。然而，我们已经看到，邦联纪念活动的可见度正变得越来越边缘化。我们现在非常接近这样一种情况，即你在美国任何地方都不会看到邦联纪念碑。不会有
nuclear submarines or anything else named after Confederate generals. So there's a stigma now, which there wasn't even 10 years ago, there's a stigma now attached to the Confederacy, which for the first time, really for the first time since the 1860s. And so how that will play out in coming generations, no one's going to write like William Faulkner anymore. No white Southern boy, unless they are self-consciously kind of radicalized and a white supremacist, are going to write with the innocent romanticism that Faulkner was able to imagine a white Southern boy writing in 1948. Is that also going to be true of, say, Lincoln and the Union? Is the idea of the Union cause as simplistically about abolishing slavery?
核潜艇或其他任何以邦联将军命名的东西。所以现在有一种耻辱感，这是10年前所没有的，现在有一种附着在邦联身上的耻辱感，这是自19世纪60年代以来真正意义上的第一次。所以这在未来几代人中会如何发展，没有人会再像威廉·福克纳那样写作了。没有哪个南方白人男孩，除非他们自觉地被激进化并且是白人至上主义者，否则不会用福克纳在1948年想象的那种天真的浪漫主义来写作。对于林肯和联邦来说，这也会是真的吗？联邦事业的想法是否简单地关于废除奴隶制？
Well, that's an interesting myth that's going to be sustainable. I think the point that you made about there being two myths of the American Civil War, the one being the the lost cause the other being the myth of the virtue of the union um that myth is a lot harder to shift not least because it has it probably has strong elements of truth it has more truth to it and um i don't think Lincoln's going to be properly cancelled anytime soon. In fact, I think I see a kind of revival of an important element of the Lincoln myth, which is the labelling of Confederates as traitors. You know, I did an interview for my podcast with Ty Sidhu, who is a white, West Point, southern-born, West Point-educated guy who's written a book called Robert E. Lee and Me, in which he talks about his... It's almost like a kind of Christian awakening story of his
嗯，那是一个可持续的有趣神话。我认为你提到的关于美国内战有两个神话的观点，一个是“迷途事业”，另一个是联邦美德的神话，嗯，那个神话更难改变，不仅因为它可能包含强有力的真理成分，它有更多的真实性，而且，嗯，我不认为林肯很快就会被彻底取消。事实上，我认为我看到了林肯神话的一个重要元素的复兴，那就是将邦联人贴上叛徒的标签。你知道，我为我的播客采访了泰·西杜，他是一个白人，西点军校毕业，南方出生，受过西点教育的人，他写了一本名为《罗伯特·E·李和我》的书，他在书中谈到了他的……这几乎就像是一种基督教觉醒故事，关于他的
recognition of the evil of this man who he had venerated in his childhood. But one of the key maneuvers that Ty makes in that book is not just his recognition that Lee was a supporter of slavery, which is shocking to him, to Ty, but also that he's a traitor. And that's something that is maybe hard for us, harder for us as non-Americans to really get on board with. Because we're like, well, you know, I mean, Lee was only a traitor because he lost the war. He was no more a traitor. And then he's only, I mean, George Washington was a traitor in the same sense. It's just he was on the winning side, right? But for someone like Ty, the fact that Lee is a traitor is like he's winning card for why lee's portrait
对这个他在童年时期崇拜的人的邪恶的认识。但泰在书中采取的关键策略之一，不仅是他认识到李是奴隶制的拥护者，这让他感到震惊，对泰来说，而且他还认为他是一个叛徒。这可能是我们作为非美国人很难真正接受的事情。因为我们想，嗯，你知道，我的意思是，李之所以是叛徒只是因为他输了战争。他并不比……我的意思是，乔治·华盛顿在同样的意义上也是一个叛徒。只是他站在了胜利的一边，对吧？但对于像泰这样的人来说，李是一个叛徒的事实就像是他为什么李的肖像
needs to be taken down from west point and why his name needs to be removed from military bases but i mean the comparison with washington isn't just a flip one i mean washington was a slave owning secessionist and so if you are pulling down statues of of lee i mean yeah pull them all down and put up george iii so you can you can definitely see how and and people on the right in american talk in this kind of way warning of the thin end of the wedge so you can definitely see how you can get from taking down statues of lee to taking down statues of jefferson and of washington i think it's harder to see how you get to taking down statues of Lincoln though, because, which is your question, because Lincoln is the re-founder of the nation and he's washed the Republican robe white to use his own language.
需要从西点军校撤下，为什么他的名字需要从军事基地中移除的王牌。但我的意思是，与华盛顿的比较不仅仅是一个轻率的比较，我的意思是，华盛顿是一个蓄奴的分离主义者，所以如果你要拆除李的雕像，我的意思是，是的，把它们全部拆掉，竖起乔治三世的雕像，所以你绝对可以看出，而且美国右翼人士以这种方式谈论，警告这是楔子的薄端，所以你绝对可以看出你如何从拆除李的雕像到拆除杰斐逊和华盛顿的雕像。但我认为很难看出你如何能拆除林肯的雕像，因为，这就是你的问题，因为林肯是国家的重建者，他用他自己的语言来说，把共和党的长袍洗白了。
And as you say, perhaps the current intensity of debate, because it is reminiscent of the kind of the violence of opinion and mood in the 1850s and 60s. Perhaps it will, you know, it'll make Lincoln stop being a kind of dead figure. It'll make him more alive, more kind of contemporary. That's what I wanted to ask Tom, because the intensity of the debate reflects an intensity of political polarization in the United States in the last 10 years or so. And, you know, when we did a podcast, one of the first podcasts in our series, and it was just, I think, before, wasn't it, Tom, the Trump-Biden election? Yeah. And it was about how civil wars start. And I don't think there's anybody who could have listened to the first episode
正如你所说，也许当前辩论的强度，因为它让人想起19世纪50年代和60年代那种暴力观点和情绪。也许它会，你知道，它会让林肯不再是一个死气沉沉的人物。它会让他更鲜活，更具当代感。这就是我想问汤姆的，因为辩论的强度反映了过去10年左右美国政治极化的强度。而且，你知道，当我们做播客时，我们系列中的第一个播客之一，我想是在，不是吗，汤姆，特朗普-拜登选举之前？是的。它是关于内战是如何开始的。我不认为有谁听了第一集
in this epic that you've done for us, Adam, showing, I have to say, Herculean stamina, who hasn hasn't i doubt there are many people who haven't thought at some point you know the united states torn apart by these terrible arguments about race um about the tension between the locality and the federal government but about what it is to be an american all of those kinds of things. And there can be very few people who've listened to all that and haven't thought about the 21st century. Do you think, I mean, is it completely fanciful to say that the same kind or similar cleavages and arguments could,
在你为我们做的这个史诗中，亚当，我必须说，展现了赫拉克勒斯般的耐力，谁没有，我怀疑没有多少人没有在某个时刻想过，你知道，美国被这些关于种族、关于地方与联邦政府之间紧张关系的、关于什么是美国人的可怕争论所撕裂，所有这些事情。很少有人听了所有这些而没有想到21世纪。你认为，我的意思是，说同样类型或类似的裂痕和争论可能会，
in frankly a heavily armed society, could lead America to a similarly dark place in the next 10 years or so. The thing that worries me is that today in the United States, for the first time since the 1850s, you have two political parties who are not only operating in their own information universes. It's not just that they don't share the same facts. It's not just that the level of polarization between them has risen to the level where, you know, whatever it is, 70% of parents don't want their child to date someone from the other party. It's that level. It's not just that. It's also that the parties are on opposite sides of all of the main cleavages in American society.
坦率地说，在一个重度武装的社会中，在未来10年左右将美国带向同样黑暗的地方，这完全是异想天开吗？让我担心的是，今天在美国，自19世纪50年代以来，你第一次有两个政党，他们不仅在各自的信息宇宙中运作。不仅仅是他们不共享相同的事实。不仅仅是他们之间的极化程度已经上升到，你知道，无论是什么，70%的父母不希望他们的孩子与来自另一个政党的人约会。就是那个程度。不仅仅是这样。而且政党处于美国社会所有主要裂痕的对立面。
So the division over race, over the historic injustice done to black Americans in particular, but also immigration and the question of cultural diversity in all of its forms. Up until a few decades ago, the political parties shared out those schisms. So, you know, historically, you had a Republican Party, which had the support of a lot of African Americans, and that was quite tolerant, relatively speaking, on race issues. And you had a Democratic Party that catered to immigrants, broadly speaking. And now on those two issues, for example, and there are many others that we could talk about, the two parties represent the two different camps. And it's impossible for me to think of an issue, a really important issue that is a real schism, you know, whether it's abortion or gun control, in which the two parties don't polarize opinion. That was the situation just before the Civil War, when the Republican Party in the North deliberately and self-consciously, in order to win a national election, gathered together all of those who
所以关于种族、关于对美国黑人造成的历史性不公正的划分，还有移民和各种形式的文化多样性问题。直到几十年前，政党还分担了这些分裂。所以，你知道，历史上，你有一个共和党，它得到了许多非裔美国人的支持，在种族问题上相对而言是相当宽容的。你有一个民主党，大体上迎合移民。而现在，在这两个问题上，例如，还有许多我们可以谈论的其他问题，这两个政党代表了两个不同的阵营。对我来说，很难想到一个问题，一个真正重要的问题，一个真正的分裂，你知道，无论是堕胎还是枪支管制，这两个政党不会使观点极化。这就是内战前的情况，当时北方的共和党为了赢得全国选举，故意且自觉地聚集了所有那些
felt threatened by slavery or by the slave power. For most of the time since, it hasn't been that case. So if things go disastrously wrong in the United States, I think that is why it will be. But it has an intensity, doesn't it, that it also had in the 1850s? Yes. So in other words, there are times in Britain where the two parties, the two main parties, have been wildly at variance on lots of issues, on almost all the key issues of the day. Labour and the Tories in the 1970s or the 1980s, let's say.
感到受到奴隶制或奴隶主权力威胁的人。在此之后的大部分时间里，情况并非如此。所以如果美国的事情变得极其糟糕，我认为这就是原因。但它有一种强度，不是吗，它在19世纪50年代也有？是的。所以换句话说，在英国，有两个政党在许多问题上，在当时几乎所有关键问题上都存在巨大分歧的时候。比如20世纪70年代或80年代的工党和保守党。
But that didn't quite have that kind of inflammatory cultural salience that made people think if we lose the next election, our entire way of life is threatened by these treacherous, dastardly, wicked people. I mean, I think there were probably moments in the 1983 general election when we came pretty close to that. But no, you're exactly right. And that is how American politics is now. It is, as you say, that sense that every election, the stakes are incredibly high because the enemies of the republic will be in control if we lose this election. So everything, everything is at stake. Our way of life, our republic, our values, everything that we hold dear are being threatened. The other side are enemies. And there's always been, I mean, this is nothing new in American history. Americans have been at each other's throats over those questions literally since the 1780s. But there are moments when it has been more intense than others. One moment was in the 1850s and another moment is right now
但这并没有那种煽动性的文化显著性，让人觉得如果我们输了下一次选举，我们的整个生活方式就会受到这些背信弃义、卑鄙、邪恶的人的威胁。我的意思是，我想在1983年的大选中可能有那么一刻我们非常接近这一点。但不，你说得完全正确。这就是现在的美国政治。正如你所说，那种感觉是每次选举，赌注都高得惊人，因为如果我们输了这次选举，共和国的敌人就会掌权。所以一切，一切都处于危险之中。我们的生活方式，我们的共和国，我们的价值观，我们所珍视的一切都受到威胁。另一方是敌人。而且一直以来，我的意思是，这在美国历史上并不新鲜。美国人从18世纪80年代开始就一直在这些问题上争得面红耳赤。但有些时刻比其他时刻更激烈。一个时刻是在19世纪50年代，另一个时刻就是现在。
uh well adam i i can't thank you enough and i i mean i think the whole this whole series uh perhaps particularly the last you know the last 20 minutes or so have been absolutely kind of ringing demonstration of the reason that history is never just history um you know the past really lives on in into the present and perhaps the future um and if you want to hear more of adam talking perhaps along these very lines i don't know uh he has his podcast the last best hope question mark um about american history an excellent podcast unmissable so thank you all so much for listening. Thank you particularly to Adam for, as Dominic said, herculean effort and four incredible episodes. What the listeners don't know is he has done this all in one go. And what is more, he's done it on his daughter's birthday,
嗯，亚当，我怎么感谢你都不为过，我的意思是，我认为整个这个系列，也许特别是最后，你知道，最后20分钟左右，绝对是一种响亮的证明，证明了历史永远不仅仅是历史的原因，你知道，过去确实活在现在，也许还有未来，如果你想听更多亚当谈论这些方面的内容，我不知道，他有他的播客《最后的希望吗？》，关于美国历史，一个优秀的播客，不可错过，所以非常感谢大家的收听。特别感谢亚当，正如多米尼克所说，赫拉克勒斯般的努力和四集令人难以置信的节目。听众不知道的是，他是一口气完成这一切的。而且更重要的是，他是在他女儿生日那天完成的，
which is really... Which may or may not be coincident. And against the terrible deadline because you're off to America tomorrow. But thank you both. This has been really good fun thank you bye bye everybody thank you bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
这真的……这可能是也可能不是巧合。而且是在可怕的截止日期前，因为你明天就要去美国了。但谢谢你们俩。这真的很有趣，谢谢，再见大家，谢谢，再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听和访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，以及在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和现场门票的抢先体验，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。